[Music]
jason derulo accuses american airlines
of racial discrimination at the miami
international airport on wednesday in an
incident involving checked baggage fees
Derulo posted to instagram acclaiming 15
police officers were called on him
following the incident but everything
was dropped once they found out he was
famous according to an incident report
obtained by miami TV station WPLG Derulo
and his entourage arrived to the airport
too late to check their 19 bags and
according to an American Airlines
employee quote all smelled of marijuana
and were starting to get aggressive TMZ
reports one person stayed behind with
the luggage while Derulo and the rest of
his crew boarded their flight but once
Derulo was made aware of a four thousand
dollar charge for the bags he stood up
on the flight and demanded they go back
to the gate resulting in a heated
argument with the pilot Derulo says he
is a concierge mmm ber of american
airlines which allows him to bring
unlimited bags on the plane an airline
representative told WPLG that even the
airline's most elite customers are only
allowed to check three complimentary
bags American Airlines later released a
statement regarding the incident a
passenger elected to deplane in order to
travel with their checked bag the
passenger has been rebooked with his
check pads on a later flight this
evening
you